- This looks good to me.
I was gonna say don't put your face in it
and I just put my face in it.
(breathes deeply)
(exhales sharply)
(upbeat music)
Hey, what's up? It's Tway.
And welcome to "Making It Big".
The show where my friends challenge me
to make their favorite foods big.
So, you might notice that my
table here is a little warped
and that's because we're
filming everything in VR.
You can watch the full VR episode
with a Meta Quest 2 in Mega Tasty.
That's our virtual cooking world
within Horizon Worlds,
or on Meta Quest TV.
Today, I have a very special guest.
It's Miss Asia Jackson.
Hi, welcome to the show.
- Thank you so much for having me.
- How are you today?
- I'm good, how are you?
- I am kind of nervous right now.
- Kind of nervous?
- Yeah.
- [Asia] As you should.
- I just don't know what
you're gonna challenge me to,
and I feel like you are very particular.
- Yes.
- So I really have
to nail this.
- Yes, you do.
- [Tway] Whatever this is.
- Absolutely, yeah.
- So, let's see it.
- All right. Here we go.
Ta-da.
- [Tway] Oh, wow.
- [Asia] Yes.
- [Tway] Vietnamese egg rolls.
- [Asia] Vietnamese egg rolls.
Look at that.
- Okay. So explain to me
why Vietnamese egg rolls.
- So I'm half Filipino, we
have our own egg roll version.
- Yeah.
- We call it lumpia.
But it's such a staple in
East and Southeast Asia,
so I was like, let's have
her show us how to make
a gigantic Vietnamese egg roll.
- Wow. What about sauce?
Do you want a dipping sauce on the side?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay. I actually have
a special sauce I make
for my egg rolls.
- Ooh.
- So if you don't mind,
I can make that for you.
- Yeah, I'd love to try it.
- I have a lot of work to do.
I will see you later.
- All right, girl.
- [Tway] Thanks, friend.
- I put my trust to you.
- Let's get to it.
First things first, the wrapper.
When I make egg rolls,
I usually just use the
wrapper from the store,
but we couldn't find
any that was big enough.
So I have my flour here.
I am going to add in some salt.
I'm adding hot water just
so it can hydrate the dough.
There has been some debate between
if this is an egg roll or a spring roll.
But you know what?
To me, this is cha gio.
That means egg roll in
Vietnamese. (chuckles)
I love playing with dough.
(upbeat music)
Put this in my bowl and
let it rest for 30 minutes.
(upbeat music)
So the reason why I
needed this dough to rest
is because I need the gluten
to just calm down a little bit
or else I won't be able to spread them out
as thin as I would like to.
(upbeat music)
I think this is the perfect
thickness for the egg roll too.
So, yeah.
I am going to let this
wrapper rest in the fridge
just so when I fill it
up with the filling,
it can stay the shape.
See you later.
(upbeat music)
(bowl clanking)
(meditation chants)
So now, I'm going to
combine my minced pork,
the shrimps, the onions.
See all this different
texture that's going in
is really going to give
it a nice mouth feel
when you bite into it.
The carrots, the noodles, the mushrooms.
Egg yolks hence egg rolls.
Green onions.
Minced garlic.
And there's already a
lot of flavors in here,
but we do need to add seasoning
because you need to season your food.
Sesame oil.
Just a little bit because
this is really over powering.
My favorite thing in the whole
entire world, fish sauce.
(speaks in Vietnamese)
It's a replacement for salt,
but it also adds that like
nice umami touch to it
when you bite into something
that's been seasoned with fish sauce.
You know that it's not just
been seasoned with salt.
It's been seasoned with love.
So we have sugar here.
Pepper.
Are you ready? 'Cause I am.
Whoa.
Nice massage.
Don't you wish you can
just get in here with me?
Here you go.
This is our filling.
(triumphant music)
I've rolled many egg rolls in my life.
I have never rolled one this big.
Let's do this.
Oop.
(bright upbeat music)
Let's close.
Everything is nice and tight.
I have my egg wash here.
(upbeat music)
Fold it over.
All right.
I think I'm ready.
(suspenseful music)
Yes.
Wow.
And this is my giant egg roll.
I hope that you cook all the way through.
If you don't, you are a disappointment.
Let's get this in the fryer.
(upbeat music)
Welcome to the back kitchen.
So I have my cha gio here.
The fryer is over there.
As you can see, the
friendly fry guy is here.
- [Voiceover] Fry guy.
Your guy to anything fry.
- I am going to stay
my butt right over here
because that's 10 gallons of hot oil
that I'm kinda scared of.
So I'm gonna hand this over to you.
Drop that egg roll.
(oil sizzles)
All right.
I'll see you in two hours.
Bye, friend.
(upbeat music)
So my baby is in the fryer.
So that gives me time to make the sauce.
Usually, I like to eat my
egg rolls with Mae Ploy,
a sweet chili sauce.
But this is my recipe, so
we'll call it Tway Ploy.
I have some Fresno chilies here
that I'm just going to give a rough chop.
And then I have some
Thai chilies over here,
Bird's eye chilies.
Okay. I have my garlic over here.
More garlic, the better.
(food processor whirring)
This looks good to me.
I was gonna say don't put your face in it
and I just put my face in it.
(suspenseful music)
- [Fry Guy] Lift up.
- Okay. Moment of truth.
I'm about to bring Asia in,
but I just want to take a quick moment
to just really take it all in
'cause I really did just
make a giant egg roll.
Look at this.
This compared to this.
Hopefully, she likes it.
Asia, please come in.
(Asia gasps)
- Oh my God. (laughs)
What the heck?
Oh my God this is huge.
- The big giant egg
roll that you asked for.
- How much does this weigh?
- It actually weighs 15 pounds.
It is 16 inches long and 6 inches wide.
You ready?
(upbeat music)
Let's see.
- Ooh.
Oh my gosh.
This is so heavy. You guys have no idea.
Okay.
- I've never-
Cheers.
- [Asia] Cheers.
- [Tway] Oh, you can dip first.
- [Asia] Oh, thank you.
- [Tway] Since you're the guest.
- [Asia] Thank you so, oh my God.
(both laughs)
- Okay.
Spice warning it might be a little spicy.
- Okay. Disclaimer you guys,
I have a very low spice tolerance.
So we'll see.
- Okay, maybe bite over there
and then you can get a lick over here.
- No, I'm just gonna go for it.
- All right.
(Asia laughs)
I warned her.
We got, we got that on camera, right?
- Okay, okay, okay.
- Okay.
- Ready?
- Yup.
- 1, 2, 3.
(suspenseful music)
Honestly, this is really good.
(both laughs)
Mm.
- Well, there you go.
My giant egg roll was a success.
- Oh, and the sauce is really good too.
- [Tway] Really?
- It's not that spicy,
it's not too spicy.
- Okay. We'll see about that.
- [Asia] Okay.
- Just wait.
I'm just kidding.
- I know.
(both laughs)
- In the comments below,
let me know what I should make big next.
And I'll see you next time.
(upbeat music)
(shutter clicking)
(beep)
- My hand is cramping
'cause this is so heavy.
- Okay. Let's put this back down.
(upbeat music)